today's topic all right right now we're
uh
how do you want to start this
we better than you better than you
we better than you [ __ ] apparently you
guys uh had some violent come to their
door
that was his problem that was his choice
yeah there was there was no because you
got triggered baby
come on in man come on
come on
[Music]
and people think that we sent
uh their former business associates
someone they worked with for a long time
to them to
attack them and break down their door
uh i appreciate it i appreciate that you
guys think that we have so much
influence that we know uh goons
everywhere that we could just centuries
how can i prove that how can i prove
that i didn't send someone to hit you i
don't know
how do you prove that but even he says
it himself he says it we say so just to
be just to make this very very clear you
know you showing up at that door had
nothing to do with gabriel and preach
okay if you guys want to believe there
were parts of grant's conspiracy i don't
really care to be honest with you go
find some proof and press charges all
right that's what i'm gonna say about
that i wouldn't have sent someone
i was about to go there myself but from
what i see they don't want that
and i can't fight a man that doesn't
want to fight
even though if he's the one that posted
the challenge why
because that's illegal
if we have our number you can call us
i've been contacting you
i've been contacting you on the dms and
you haven't replied you've seen it but
you haven't replied
you know that so for that i know that
you don't want none of this this [ __ ]
preach shows up he's gonna fight you're
going to lose other it is what it is
and the truth hurts it's not [ __ ]
acceptable to insult a man's country and
or wife make your bed and sleep in it
there's consequences to your [ __ ]
actions oh [ __ ] okay
all these other dramas that are coming
down the baby mamas the people we're not
going to cover all that so what we paid
that too we paid we paid all government
we're not going to come out
right then he's talking to women he says
you want to get in this podcast well we
can only do it if you [ __ ] is that how
you conduct your business right how are
you giving people business lessons but
you [ __ ] where you work does anyone find
it funny that this man's bad business
practices are coming out to bite his
business in the ass and he's giving you
guys all the business advice there's an
incongruence here that i find hilarious
how is it a good business strategy to go
message a random woman say you want to
get on this podcast i would love to have
you on let's collaborate she's like okay
sure you're like are you single because
i only work with people i'm banking
is that a good business practice
is that burning desire that you
mentioned it unlike these idiots we can
actually get girls these dudes have
probably never even smelled a woman
they've never had genuine burning
desires nope because no one wants to eat
the fat leftover
well the sexist transaction when we
don't have it that's exactly what you do
and you're saying the way you acquire a
woman sometimes is even more important
than how then acquiring her and what i
mean by that is oh you're not going to
get her best if you pay for it and if
you're content with that that's okay
yeah but you know uh me and fresh
personally and this is a man to me each
guy is different right some guys don't
care how they get it some guys are okay
with paying for it but like me and fresh
personally we're like we want this
girl's best you know what i'm saying we
want it when you say red on
and you're seeing all this messiness
that you're having with all these women
that you're trying to sleep with
right they're all airing you out
wouldn't have been way more convenient
if you had a solution for
a way to have sex transactionally with
women
so it doesn't come back to bite you in
the ass
so that when they leave
that if it was transactional you may not
have problems you would have paid and it
would have been that
but some guys they just want the box and
they don't want to deal with the bs and
i get it i'm never going to knock it
because real talk dealing women is a
headache
i'm not going to lie
this is the funny thing about these guys
they want to have transactional sex but
they say cloud is acceptable but not
money because it's so different
it's not it's the same thing whether
it's a goat whether it's a cow whether
it's gold bars or cash it's all
transactional
and i just want to make it clear i'm not
even saying some of these allegations
are necessarily true or not what i'm
saying is that there's a reason why
people pay for these women's services
it's to avoid the headache that comes
with it afterwards so for someone who
claims he doesn't want drama and doesn't
want to deal with all this stuff maybe
the solution for you in certain
situations was to pay for some bucks
instead of clout give them money
i'll grill you deal with women western
society is it worth it to me in my
opinion not really because what do you
get from it nothing i'm a girl you
deal with women watching society is it
worth it to me in my opinion not really
because
what do you get from it nothing
guys by the way real quick
deep down secret i i just got to give
you the the hard truth man
i sucked three different dicks yesterday
and i [ __ ] five guys last week and as
a matter of fact i lost my virginity at
19 in a threesome getting eiffel tower
we don't have to do all this on the
internet we can box we've said it a
plethora of times don't play with
violence
don't don't mention it don't say you're
about it don't say you want to do it
because the more you talk about how you
want to be violent don't be surprised
when it comes to find you
i'm not saying you deserve this i'm
saying there's an action and there's
often times a reaction actions have
reactions
and violence begets more violence the
reason why violence is bad and i
understand that violence is bad and i
took their challenge you have to
understand as well what i said i said i
wanted to make this thing legal because
the violence is not necessary i'm not
going to scrap in the streets
i'm not going to have
put myself in a position where it's
going to be bad no i wanted a ring i
wanted a ring i wanted people to be safe
in the most safe environment that's why
i said i want that thing to be legal
i wasn't about to cut catch them catch
them off and then beat the guy that's
not what i wanted you want a fair fight
let's go
because i do fair fights i do every man
i do i do a different martial arts in a
fair setting i understand that the
streets is different there's no rules in
the streets that's not what i want so
there's different type of violence but
people
you brought up a challenge of boxing and
i was there
but if you keep on challenging people
certain other people are not gonna take
it like that and are literally gonna
take it in the street and are literally
gonna have like an on-site mentality
that's why i wanted to bring it up in a
safe space
i said save space y'all [ __ ]
made me say safe space
[ __ ] when you say i want to box people
and you've not just said it to us you
send it to other subscribers other
youtubers who just don't happen to be as
willing or as interested right people
who are far smaller than you guys as you
guys perceive it you guys were very
comfortable saying how you were going to
fight if there is one thing that gets me
mad it's fat dudes that talk smack man
like i absolutely detest obese people
that talk smack because the last thing
they should be doing is working out
their mouth they need to be working out
their body oh so when blubber boy is out
here talking smack they're lucky i
couldn't find their girl
because i would send him a dm
flown all to miami and send them that
tape
anyhow yeah look at that i can't find
her oh there we go up is that is that
low is that a wild low right now that
we're about to see oh look at that we
got
that albert number two mr low yo aka
this guy does not have an instagram by
the way guys which i'm not surprised he
does have an instagram he doesn't have
one
because if i look like that i would not
be on instagram either what are those
seriously man guys i'm about to evolve
oh
oh my god what's going on right now
unlike these idiots we can actually get
girls these dudes have probably never
even smelled a woman they've never had
genuine burning desires nope because no
one wants to eat the fat laptop quick
diversion from roasting playback yeah
i'ma call this right now steve is old
bald fat and he ain't in the game no
more and he's wifed up with a single mom
all right he's a bum i challenged him to
a boxing match he ain't accepted he was
scared he's stupid and i'll tell you
guys and he was trying to act tough and
everything like that i told him very
calmly when me and solo were talking
with him he was trying to be tough like
good solo admirer
i'm like bruh listen
we don't have to do all this on the
internet we can box right and by the way
for anyone that doesn't know steve dean
is about five foot six and 200 pounds
with a stomach out this far bro he's
snorlax number two you know what i'm
saying bro this is your pattern it's
documented it's online for everyone to
see people critique your videos say we
don't believe you and you guys talk
about how they look you guys talking
non-stop about how how you gonna fight
them someone might be like oh you bout
that violence life and you did something
to me i'ma come find you this person
that we supposedly said that's your
business associate they gotta beef with
you you're a former photographer he's
the one who's airing you out you have to
start to ask yourself how do i have so
many bad business relationships how is
that so many of the guests who i claim i
treated supremely well come out and say
these guys have no character at some
point you have to start looking inwardly
and start to ask yourself was i nearly
as hospitable as i claimed was that
nearly as good to these people as i
claim and if you didn't
there may be some readjusting you have
to do and it's okay i think none of us
are perfect i think redemption is good
for everybody this whole talk about
cancer who advocated cancer someone
calling you out on your [ __ ] and
saying that's [ __ ] wet it isn't
canceled for so-called alpha males
everybody wants things to be done in
private and quietly
y'all get on this podcast so you want to
dunk on all these ladies
publicly because you think that's cool
you're willing to play the game when
you're the one that has the ball yeah
when you're getting gunk on you don't
want to do that you don't want none of
that be very careful how you treat
people on your way up
because you might meet them on your way
down it is all the people that you had
on your way up that are now coming for
you on your way down but i dare [ __ ]
too
next year this time we're going to lap
you [ __ ] because you know what
nobody works harder than us no period i
also want to say congratulations for
hitting 400k twice
they didn't need it yet but they're
gonna hit it what do you mean they hit
it on the way up
oh you guys are talking about integrity
when you start hey listen we're honest
we're petty
we can be petty sometimes it's enjoyable
and it's kind of fun
the only way left for the normal guy to
become a high value man fresh and fit
giving away their jealousy guarded
secrets for scoring nines and tens and
more in 2021 while increasing smv myron
has triple digit lay count and fresh as
quadruple digit i'd have a hard time
believing that fresh has a double digit
lay count hey guys we're fresh prince
ceo and today we're gonna talk about all
my w's stay tuned for it ladies watching
this how believable is it that this guy
has slept with more than a thousand
women we need some type of blood test
where you can prove if someone is still
a virgin like a blood test for proven if
someone is on gear or not you can have
walter go and get checked for one of his
blogs it's likely you've never heard of
us though we've been content to keep a
pretty low profile and remain behind the
scenes the rational male rollo tomasi
has seen us in action
we haven't heard of you because no one
credible promoted you what myron and
walter have done is basically take
everything the red pill fake gurus say
and spit it out on their jerry springer
show i can't even get through this video
rolo tomasi has seen us in action what
action are you talking about because i
know rallo isn't getting allowed into
the miami nightclubs except for our
lighting fast growth in youtube
currently at 22k subscribers with only a
few months we've never tried to promote
ourselves self-aggrandize and do all
that chess beating nonsense necessary to
be a player in the overcrowded guru
market long story short i'm going to
give you a few cool surprises when you
take advantage of the high value academy
yes they've never done any fake guru
stuff like made videos lying about their
success with women walter specifically
has done everything on the fake guru
checklist but if we're being honest we
know that a lot of muslims are in this
game
are liars
they could talk all this stuff you put
them in front of women
right and they look like a comatose
patient so it's just important to see
who's really about it and if they're not
then you need to discard them we only
mess with people that are actually real
if you're not real we don't
that was ironic a month ago walter
continued on with the paid press
releases tour to build up his fake guru
brand walter weeks is cementing his name
in the music industry age 20 week's
lyrical prowess and music writing skills
are exceptional he has proven to be an
excellent songwriter and poet composing
captivating songs weeks has also
established himself as a music producer
a master of his craft weeks's music
production skills have resulted in him
being one of the youngest sought-after
music producers in the us he is a force
to reckon with in the industry and is
expected to gain more prominence in the
near future his previously paid press
releases introduced him into the game of
helping people with a lifestyle in women
he basically creates the press release
before the grift begins so my guess is
this is signaling his next grift of
getting into the music business his
immediate aspirations are to establish a
music record label to hone his
production skills he also intends to
start producing his own music and he
feels that creating his record label is
the right step good luck to the artist
trying to sign to his label if it even
exists these guys have a product called
dms on demand which is going to show you
how to dm the most beautiful women in
your city and get them on dates when i
fixed my profile and tapped into that
hidden ten percent of guys who have
status and game i had the women i
dreamed about the women that i
previously thought were way out of my
league were now messaging me to hang out
with them the women that once rejected
me for not being interesting and having
a high value lifestyle now wanted to be
friends with me and the women who are
attracted to the top 10 of guys were now
begging me for alone time together with
all of these amazing women myron is
dating it's amazing that he doesn't have
any receipts on his instagram page it's
funny that the screenshots proving that
this system works includes what is
insinuated to be myron's dm inbox which
no proof is provided so that's flaw
number one flaw number two is that blue
checkmark girls are not dming a guy like
myron who has very little clout in the
social media world flaw number three is
that i've never seen an inbox look like
this flaw number four is the date stone
align from top to bottom the dates are
14 hours three weeks eight weeks one
week and one week they aren't even in
chronological order so clearly this is a
fake image proof that their system works
is a clearly photoshopped image what
would be funny is having myron show his
instagram dms live on the podcast but we
all know why he would never do that or
maybe we do know what would happen
thanks to kevin ray wilder for making
this video okay now
no hell no
we're not doing it we're not doing it so
uh let's uh why are you scared no it's
not that i'm scared bro
this is the perfect ending to this video
these girls were reviewing walter's
instagram and absolutely roasting it one
even said he looks like a scammer after
walter was abused live on air he said it
was myron's turn myron shut that down
quickly knowing that any criticism from
women would have destroyed the facade
that he has blue checkmark women sending
him dms so that was spencer cornelius
video i thought he did a great job and
it just goes to show you guys just how
much lies and faking it till you make it
goes into any one of these videos so we
want to just tell you guys stop playing
with violence do not encourage that you
want to critique the ideas go ham you
want to go react to our videos go ham i
don't really care but just advice to
anybody on this platform don't play with
violence don't don't encourage it don't
say we bout it don't don't do none of
that
because it has a funny way of finding
you when you least expect it and in this
sense i do
um empathize
with the fresher fit crew i know what
it's like when somebody breaks into your
home
i know what it's like to no longer feel
safe there it's a frightening thing the
place that you were supposed to always
have some sense of peace and serenity
it's jeopardized all the barriers are
broken everything is done everything is
done and now you're out in the open you
feel naked i feel that and i also say
this you guys bring these people to your
home to do these podcasts and you don't
vet them well enough i know because you
end up kicking up so many your guests
it's not normal that you invite guests
only to kick them out all the time you
guys need to do a better job of letting
these people that you bring on because
this is a new person that you're
inviting that you may disrespect or say
something foul to who may come to find
you at your place of residence this is a
pro tip to you and to anybody else if
you're going to bring random people into
your home actually just don't have a
separate office space okay but you know
all in all him defending his face i'm
not mad at it um i would just say just
again
it's a dangerous business practice and i
don't want anybody to get hurt doing
that or from that example i know it cuts
down on costs of using your own space
and all that stuff you get to smash the
wind right afterwards but understand
you're putting yourself at risk
having a gun is great for protection you
know what's better than guns prevention
all right so just stay safe out there
[Music]
second
m
[Music]